fighter 5 vendredi en apéro à 20h05 j'ai
regardé le facebook like de maxime gagné
chez télé loisirs ont débrief le passage
de maxime à paris le début il a été bien
beau l'ère moderne
regardez ça lui maxime à 31 ans mais il
parle comme un homme de 80 ans et les
mêmes plus fous et c'est reparti comme
en 40
c'est la toile est aussi kelly c'est la
super copine de maxime
d'ailleurs quand il l'appelle elle
décroche forcément enfin j'imagine t'as
qu'à te regarde et il me regarde oui on
sait où on connaît la passion de maxime
pour la magie du coup il a tenté un tour
de magie
attention grand moment de tristesse et
celle ça comme ça de cette manière
à l'aller nous et tombe par terre tout
homme normalement s'il fait sa purée ils
foutent en l'air face à john lennon
comme sa dernière
à bord les magiciens qui nous file c'est
comme ça
on y suit la réalisation magnifique
[Applaudissements]
merci
maxime
ouah moi je vous le dis je vous avais je
vous défendrai toujours si beaucoup
c'est formidable tous soyez un beau duo
maxime gagné julien lepers oh oui
pourquoi pas bon jeu et les bons mots à
les hashtag race rare